hey folks it's your old friend crazy
Pete from crazy feats of arson and
embryonic stem cell Emporium and I've
got a deal that will knock your socks
hope you got double are now on sale that
was funnier than a white stallion follow
it bud well let me tell you something
it's not funny
Milton ice cubes and dine coca-cola
bears on account of global warming most
humans just can't get their crap
together and so it's hotter than Valley
Park on a bouncy hop but that's where
I'm here to tell you about crazy beats
and my ruling
[Music]
whatever you learn about the Leeds uncle
crazy page got him
we've got reusable grocery bags electric
cars windmills and you pitch your folks
it seems a need to go green has hurt a
lot of American businesses but not your
own run crazy P and that's why you need
to come on down to crazy Pete's in my
room friendly discount Galleria tried to
pay tomorrow family discount Galleria
screw in American ingenuity the middle
class and slashing prices
[Music]